frfrontièrere ukrainienne. Merc.
AvAvec nous,
GéGérard Araud, diplomate
etet ex-ambassadeur de France
àà W Washington.
MoMonsieur Pououtine, c'est le d
dudu problèmeme, il veut une
gagarantie que l'Ukraine ne soit
jajamais acceptée au sein de
l'l'OTAN. On va avoir une carte
totout à l l'heure. Les pays bls
onont entouré de plus en plus
fofortement la Russie.
EsEst-ce que vous voyez encore e
sosoir l'option diplomatique coe
ététant une voie réaliste pour e
MoMonsieur Poutine trouve une ve
dede sortie et que les Européens
etet Américains aussi?
- - C'est allé un peu vite. La
pepensée de donner cette garante
quque réclame Monsieur Poutine
memettrait fin au conflit.
MoMonsieur Poutine s'est très sn
ququelle entrée de l'Ukraine das
l'l'OTAN n'est absolument pas ds
leles considérations dans les 10
ouou 20 prochaines années.
PoPourquoi il était nécessaire e
fafaire cette crise? C'est la
prpremièrere question qu'il faue
poposer. Tu veveux vraiment Monr
PoPoutine? De nouveau, on ne fat
papas la guerre pour une
évéventualité qui pourrait arrir
dadans les 15 prochaines années.
N'N'oubliez pas l'article quatre
écécrit Monsieur Poutine en
jujuillet sur l'Ukraine, où il
didisait à l la fin : nous sommn
mmêmeme peuple. On peut craindre
quque l'objectif réel de la Ruse
sosoit annexé l'Ukraine à s sa
spsphèrere d'influence.
- - Ce que vous dîtetes, c'est e
MoMonsieur Poutine ne cherche ps
unune porte de sortie, mais un
prprétexte pour entrer en Ukrai.
- - Non, c'est une question. Il
n'n'y a que Monsieur Poutine qui
pepeut y répondre. C'est une
cacaractéristique du systèmeme e
ququi est totalement vertical. e
miministre des affaires étrangès
nene sait pas vraiment ce que vt
vrvraiment Poutine. Jusqu'à
mamaintenant, on l'a vu avec le
cicinq heurts d'entretien
d'd'Emmanuel Macron, peut-êtrtre
ququ'on le verra avec le
chchancelier allemand, mais on a
papas vraiment l'impression que
PoPoutine veut une négociation.
PePendant les cinq heures
d'd'entretien avec Emmanuel
MaMacron, ça a été des heures et
dedes heures ou Poutine a répété
totous ses sentiments de
frfrustration, tous les malheurs
dede la Russie au cours des 30
dedernièreres années. Donc,
ilil est difficile de savoir
jujusqu'où il peut aller, qu'els
sosont vraiment les concessions
ququ'il demande.
- - Et de l'autre côtété, c'est
asassez rare de voir les
coconférences de presse à
WaWashington, celle de vendredi
dedernier, hier on disait que
c'c'est imminent, c'est mêmeme
memercredi que Moscou va attaqu.
OnOn a changé un peu le discours
auaujourd'hui. Mais on a
l'l'impression que Washington
ététait convaincu qu'une attaque
ararrivait. Il le disait
ououvertement, c'est quand mêmee
inincroyable.
- - Je dois avouer que je ne
cocomprends pas. Je n'ai jamaisu
enen 40 ans les États-Unis se
mmètrtrent dans une position de
cocommentateur. Il commente
l'l'actualité en disant : ils vt
atattaquer mercredi. C'est quand
mmêmeme extrêmemement curieux. e
n'n'est pas une politique.
JeJe ne vois pas vraiment quel t
l'l'objectif des États-Unis dans
cece genre de déclaration.
PePeut-êtrtre ont-ils un syndroe
KaKaboul, ils ne veulelent pas e
susurpris par un désastre.
SiSi les Russes attaquent, ils
popourront dire : on vous l'avat
didit. Si les Russes n'attaquent
papas, ils pourront dire : c'est
grgrâcece à n nous qu'ils n'onts
atattaqué.
IlIl y a eu beaucoup de
dédéclaration extrêmemement étr.
- - On le sait, les Américains e
vovont pas dire à M Monsieur Poe
c'c'est hors de question que
l'l'Ukraine fasse partie de
l'l'OTAN.
PoPoutine ne recevra pas
tototalement ce qu'il veut.
SiSi tant est que c'est son
prprétexte, est-ce que vous vous
atattendez malheureusement à u e
ininvasion? Quelles sont les
prprobabilités qu'on se retrouve
avavec une guerre?
- - D'abord, plusieurs choses.
IlIl est tout à f fait possiblee
didire que l'Ukraine n'entrera s
dadans l'OTAN sans porter atteit
àà u un principe. Vous donnait a
unun bon diplomate, premièrere
papartie l'OTAN et ouverte à t s
leles pays, deuxièmeme partie,
l'l'OTAN est ouvert aux pays qui
sasatisfont certains critèreres.
OnOn peut donner des garanties i
vrvraiment on veut donner des
gagaranties. C'est la premièrere
chchose. On n'a pas besoin
d'd'aller tout au bout de ce que
dedemande la Russie pour lui
fofournir des garanties.
- - Pourquoi on ne lui donne pas
alalors?
- - La vraie question qu'on se
popose tous et est-ce que ça
susuffira? Poutine est extrêmemt
vavague dans ses demandes. Et
elelles sont
exextrêmemement général.
IlIl se plaint de plein de chos,
dede la sécurité européenne.
PoPour répondre à v votre quest,
atattaquer l'Ukraine peut se fae
dede 10 manièreres différentesÇa
pepeut êtrtre une attaque
ininformatique. Ça peut êtrtre s
frfrappes aériennes, l'occupatin
dede certaines villes. Il y a
unun ensemble d'options
lala guerre totale et des
inincidents, il a encore le cho.
- - On va se reparler. Merci
bebeaucoup de vos lumièreres.
EtEt comme vous dîtetes, le seui
a a les réponses à c ces questis